[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP on se retrouve
autour d'un plat et d'un dessert ainsi
que de notre invité aujourd'hui pour
parler cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et politique bonjour Dominique
schœlcher bonjour et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour
vous êtes PDG de Système U Dominique
Schelcher le quatrième distributeur
alimentaire qui compte 1500 points de
vente et 65000 collaborateurs pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 23 milliards
d'euros en 2021 systèmeus est un groupe
coopératif qui regroupe des enseignes
comme Hyper U Super U Express
utile un réseau de proximité vous
succédez à serge Papin en 2018 pour un
mandat de 6 ans vous êtes également
directeur de Système U de Fessenheim qui
était au départ une épicerie coopérative
gérée par vos parents une suite logique
donc alors que vous auriez beaucoup plus
mal tourné en persistant dans le
journalisme à l'Alsace notamment vous
avez commencé on n'échappe pas à son
destin ni à ses origines qui ont
d'ailleurs largement inspiré le menu du
jour Jean-Pierre avec un escargot de
viande les flèches NACA j'espère que
j'ai bien prononcé et on desserre à
moelleux au chocolat dans le dessous des
plats la viande remplacée par des
substituts végétaux et les Français en
redemandent reportage dans cette
émission dans les pieds d'ampleur cette
période de baisse de pouvoir d'achat
c'est la grande offensive en France des
magasins art discount pour casser les
prix allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et confidence
alors au début Dominique Schoelcher j'ai
cru que vous aviez plagié volontairement
Étienne Châtellier en donnant à votre
livre le même titre que son film à
succès le bonheur est dans le pré mais
en fait vous n'évoquez pas la prairie
vous vous évoquez le prêt de oui le à
côté de c'est ça pour dire réinventer le
commerce de proximité bref tout un
programme que dit chez même votre mantra
et quand on vous demande ce que vous
voulez déguster et bien vous répondez
naturellement mon bonheur est dans le
prêt à côté à proximité on a donc droit
Brigitte naturellement à une recette
alsacienne née sans doute tout près de
chez vous à Colmar voilà donc comment on
échappe à la bouillabaisse marseillais
700 km beaucoup trop loin trop exotique
ou au bœuf bourguignon toujours trop
éloigné de votre Alsace natal plus
Chauvin que vous on meurt Brigitte ne
fait pas cette tête pour nous c'est
l'inverse le bonheur sera donc
aujourd'hui plutôt dans l'exotique
l'inconnu et je compte sur vous pour
bien nous vendre cette recette vous
l'expert en tête de gondole
écoutez c'est vraiment déjà la société
formidable et je me réjouis de partager
ça avec vous alors pourquoi d'abord
parce que c'est une vraie recette que
tous les alsaciens qui regardent cette
émission reconnaîtront en Alsace c'est
un plat très très connu mais pour moi
c'est aussi un plat madeleine de Proust
pourquoi parce que ce plat en fait mes
parents étaient très occupés quand
j'étais petit et donc j'ai en partie
élevé par une tente donc c'était la
recette favorite et donc me replonger
dans ce plat aujourd'hui c'est aussi un
peu retourné en enfonce à mes racines en
fait vous en mangez souvent aujourd'hui
où ça reste vraiment un plat très
occasionnel pour vous ah non on en mange
à la maison régulièrement j'ai de
nombreux enfants et c'est un plat qu'ils
adorent il y a même une version un peu
plus exotique que je valide moins mais
au poisson voilà là c'est à base de
viande et ça c'est la recette
traditionnelle mais dans mon magasin
j'en vends aujourd'hui même à base de
poissons à base de saumon à Fessenheim
absolument et alors vous vous savez
préparer via une recette familiale qui
vous a été transmise par votre temps
alors je ne la prépare pas
personnellement c'est vrai que c'est un
peu un peu compliqué mais j'ai la
recette de ma tante et puis quand
j'aurai peut-être un peu plus de temps
je m'y remettrai alors en tous les cas
sachez que l'on trouve à Paris puisque
je l'ai trouvé à la maison Schmidt qui
est un traiteur alsacien et ils en font
sous vide et il y a beaucoup de clients
j'ai vu qu'ils viennent chercher leur
flèche Naka c'est une excellente chez
eux pour les Alsaciens et les
non-alsatiens à Paris près de la gare de
l'Est visuellement vous vous disiez que
ça ressemblait à ce que vous aviez
l'habitude de manger on va la goûter
pour voir le goûter je ne sais pas si
c'est féminin ou masculin on le voit
plutôt au pluriel
c'est un peu des lasagnes alsaciennes
non puisque c'est un mélange de viande
des pâtes voilà c'est un escargot de
viande fait à base de de pâtes de pâtes
à nouilles dans lequel on enroule de la
viande hachée un mélange de viande
hachée et le tout est d'abord grillé à
la poêle et vous le raconter mais
on voit que ça parfaitement était bien
préparé et c'est ensuite présenté comme
ça les là dans un bouillon alors pendant
que vous le dégustez tranquillement
Jean-Pierre trois choses à savoir sur
les flèches je vais faire très court
parce qu'on avait un spécialiste donc il
m'a un peu spoilé comme on dit mais je
ne suis pas du tout vexé parce que je
découvre ce plat je ne le connaissais
pas effectivement bon d'abord j'ai vu
c'est un escargot de viande donc j'ai un
peu pris peur je me suis dit tiens il y
a des escargots et de la viande non pas
du tout c'est comme si roulait
effectivement c'est la forme d'une
coquille mais en fait c'est une recette
très anti-gaspi puisqu'on reprend les
restes du pot-au-feu de la veille et on
fait une pâte à spetzel c'est-à-dire une
patte à nouille on l'étend à moi j'ai vu
on l'étale on met cette farce on rajoute
un peu de persil un peu d'oignon un peu
d'échalotes et cette viande et ensuite
on la roule on en fait des petites
tranches qu'on fait dorer dans le beurre
c'est ce qu'a fait chez Françoise le
chef et ensuite on met un petit peu de
bouillon et on sert ça avec une une
salade voilà et on mais je crois qu'on
met un peu de riesling du Racing dans la
sauce dans le bouillon un peu de vin le
bouillon et on laisse le effectivement
autour on laisse le bouillon autour qui
qui pénètre un peu ce qui a été grillé
on mange d'abord l'escargot et on finit
par manger le bouillon à la fin et c'est
servi en général avec une petite salade
verte voilà c'est parfait la petite
salade verte là c'est une spécialité
très connue en Alsace qu'on connaît bien
la choucroute évidemment moins les
flèches
un rayon très important dans mon magasin
et chez tous mes collègues c'est le
rayon charcuterie traiteur à la coupe
évidemment ce produit là figure en bonne
position de nos ventes de ce qui a
attendu des clients et c'est un plat
voilà qui est apprécié qui est très
familial on coupe des tranches et non
non c'est une institution alsacienne
quand on parle de pot-au-feu ça vous
fait bondir ou c'est réellement la base
de la recette de cette non mais tout à
fait vous savez aujourd'hui un grand
sujet c'est l'antigaspillage
particulièrement dans notre métier ben
ce ce plat là était dans les traditions
familiales un plat Ant gentil gaspillage
et un pas un peu roboratif dire que on a
on a cette tradition du pot-au-feu on a
aussi les viandes de choucroute etc et
souvent pour pas gaspiller les petits
morceaux etc ça cette viande était mixée
hachée et réutilisé dans ce plat là et
donc voilà c'est aussi un plat familial
historique anti-gaspillage un peu je
parle de votre chauvinisme je l'ai
regardé effectivement dans les magasins
de votre région on en vend mais est-ce
que dans les magasins les Super U qui
sont très éloignés de la l'Alsace vous
arrivez à écouler ce genre de produits
moins moins par contre ce qu'on fait
chez u il y a 35 bassins de consommation
qu'on a identifié avec tous les produits
locaux de ce bassin là l'Alsace la
Bretagne le Dauphiné Lyon et ce qu'on
fait de temps en temps on fait des
croisements c'est à dire que nous on va
vendre les produits alsaciens en
Bretagne les Bretons viennent nous
vendre leur sardines et leurs crêpes et
on se rend compte que il y a beaucoup de
curiosités de nos clients autour de ces
produits là et donc dans ce pas
d'opération là oui on peut vendre mais
en dehors en temps normal non c'est pas
assez connu et vous vous le préparez pas
tellement ça mais vous cuisinez un petit
peu vous aimez ça alors j'ai
malheureusement alors je suis très
gourmand voilà ça c'est sûr mais c'est
madame qui cuisine à la maison et elle
les cuit aussi bien que le chef l'a fait
aujourd'hui je dirais voilà et c'est
pour vous déconstruire de temps en temps
vous avez pas envie de mettre la main à
la pâte alors ce que je fourneaux par
contre est beaucoup pour mes enfants je
leur fais des desserts par contre il
paraît que mon cake marbré et
particulièrement quelle particulièrement
bon donc voilà un peu de sucré de temps
en temps mais c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai
pas beaucoup de temps et c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt les enfants et puis et puis
leur maman qui qui font la cuisine on
parlera de pâtisserie tout à l'heure
mais c'est plus fastidieux pourtant la
pâtisserie la cuisine vous avez pas de
temps en temps vous vous qui êtes au
milieu des ingrédients des aliments
toute la journée j'avais pas envie
d'essayer
alors là où là où je rectifie c'est que
j'ai une double vie ma double vie ça
fait un jour là le titre du journal
régional l'Alsace et ma femme double vie
de Monsieur schœlcher mais le rappelle
régulièrement c'est un roman ça je suis
du lundi matin ou jeudi soir à Paris
pour gérer la coopérative système et
donc évidemment je me retrouve chez moi
le soir et là je cuisine mais vraiment
un tout petit peu parce que mes journées
sont longues et j'avoue que le soir en
rentrant le soir chez moi des petites
choses toutes simples qui sont pas
forcément
pas forcément alsacienne plutôt bretonne
d'ailleurs j'adore les sardines par
exemple et vous descendez pas dans la
rue allez fureté pour trouver des bons
plans pour vous sortir de votre Colmar
je sais Colmar c'est important non mais
absolument je sors dans le quartier de
Montparnasse en l'occurrence et il y a
plein de choses à découvrir et à
déguster par contre je me refuse de
faire une chose je ne me suis jamais
fait livrer un plat à domicile je refuse
je refuse parce que c'est pas un modèle
social que je salue je dis voilà c'est
souvent des gens malheureusement dans
avec des conditions à peu précaires qui
ont pédalé pour vous je n'aime pas ce
concept là comme je ne l'aime pas dans
notre métier c'était le bout mais il y a
quelques temps du
Quick commerce se faire livrer en 10
minutes un paquet de papier WC ou un
paquet de pâtes on est on est contre ça
chez eux quoi vous dites qu'il y a une
un rayon avec les spécialités
alsaciennes qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve
qu'on connaîtrait pas nous qui ne sommes
pas de chez vous alors écoutez la base
dans ce rayon là c'est beaucoup de
charcuteries et dans ces charcuteries il
y a quelque chose qu'on connaît moins à
Paris c'est ce qu'on appelle les
roulades donc c'est que c'est comment
vous présenter ça ce sont donc ce sont
des rouleaux qu'on coupe en fines
tranches et c'est comment dire c'est
c'est de la viande de porc en fait mixer
en rouleau et par exemple les enfants
adore ça en Alsace
non c'est plus mou que du saucisson
c'est 100% du porc il y a plein de
sortes différentes et donc là pour le
repas du soir très souvent ou pour le
petit sandwich quand il faut faire un
sandwich pour midi les gens utilisent ça
il y a les gendarmes aussi alors les
gendarmes on est un peu à Paris c'est
également
non non le gendarme n'est pas dans la
choucroute les gens et au bord de la
route
le gendarme est une charcuterie
également à base de porc qui se mange
froid
c'est assez fumé assez épicé et ça moi
je me souviens de mon père par exemple
le soir il se faisait un simple pas
d'une bonne baguette qu'on a devant nous
et un gendarme et ça lui faisait son
repas une saucisse non non c'est dur on
a un peu plus c'est plus dur et c'est
plutôt rectangulaire en fait c'est assez
long rectangulaire
alors pour moi ça ne fait pas partie de
la choucroute là c'était je sais pas
normal j'ai découvert aussi quelque
chose je connaissais pas vous Brigitte
la Mauricette ah la Mauricette un petit
pain fait avec de la pâte à bretzel
c'est ça exactement bon qui qui est
aujourd'hui fourré que je vends dans mon
magasin on en prépare tous les jours
j'ai quelqu'un qui prépare des sandwichs
au magasin et et l'inventeur de de cette
petite brioche c'est Paul Poulaillon qui
est qui est un de mes fournisseurs par
ailleurs que je connais très bien qui a
inventé ce produit là et qui aujourd'hui
navigue on envoie maintenant
régulièrement à Paris vous avez l'air de
bien m'y connaître vous y connaître
Dominique schœlcher on va passer au quiz
pour voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable
alors j'ai le regret de vous dire que la
grande distribution n'a pas attendu
Super U avant de s'implanter en France
parmi ces dates clés de la grande
distribution lesquels sont vraies ou
fausses en 1948 à Paris s'ouvre la
première épicerie en libre service
c'est-à-dire qu'on servait soi-même un
concept né en Grande-Bretagne est-ce que
cette affirmation est vraie ou fausse il
y a des pièges
pour moi les vrais alors elle est vraie
parce que si en 1948 mais le concept de
libre-service lui est né aux États-Unis
plutôt qu'en Grande-Bretagne c'était le
piège donc elle est fausse d'accord mais
que le libre parce que souvent on croit
que le libre-service est arrivé par
Michel Édouard Leclerc par Édouard
Leclerc ou par Carrefour etc mais il
était présent à Paris avant ça c'est
vrai dans ce sens-là
ça amène ma deuxième affirmation puisque
vous la devancé parce que vous êtes très
très très expert en 1959 Michel-Edouard
Leclerc ouvre lui sa première enseigne
ce magasin en libre-service à Landerneau
vrai ou faux c'est faux c'est pas Michel
Édouard c'est Edouard c'est son père
alors c'était Édouard non c'était faux
parce que c'était en 1949 mais alors
autant que moi d'accord
c'était bien c'était faux parce que
c'était en 1949 donc toi tout de suite
après la première création
c'est le premier supermarché parisien
ouvre ses portes en 1957 vrai ou faux
c'est vrai ouais bravo et c'est mammouth
qui inaugure le premier hypermarché
français en 1963 à
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois est-ce que
c'est vrai
alors mammouth inaugure le non c'est pas
mammouth
autant pour moi pour le B mais presque
tout juste pour Monsieur schœlcher
deuxième quiz pour vous l'Alsacien la
choucroute a-t-elle encore des secrets
les affirmations suivantes sont-elles
vraies ou fausses a dans la choucroute
alsacienne on ajoute du gingembre en
poudre
faux du carvi mais bien sûr
mais le mot choucroute vient des mots
chou aigre en allemand est-ce que c'est
vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
en allemand absolument
dans lequel est servi la choucroute
s'appelle un artilleur vrai ou faux
j'ai jamais entendu ce nom j'ai envie de
dire que c'est faux c'est faux un
torpilleur voilà ça vous parle un petit
peu plus j'avais jamais entendu l'autre
donc et dès la choucroute au homard et
flambée au kirsch alsacien
non mais là là écoutez je
c'est
ce n'est pas sérieux de parler de
choucroute sans charcuterie et donc avec
du poisson donc je dis que c'est faux
mais c'est ton whisky quand même
il y a quand même un petit peu d'alcool
est-ce que vous faites vous devinez que
cette chair toutes vos courses dans des
magasins si je t'amus Super U
en Alsace bien évidemment et
particulièrement dans mon magasin bien
sûr
à Paris j'avoue que par curiosité je
circule un peu à gauche à droite et là
c'est plutôt avec le regard du
professionnel pour découvrir d'autres
concepts d'autres offres moi je suis un
amoureux des produits un amoureux je
vous ai dit d'abord je suis gourmand
ensuite je suis un vrai amoureux des
produits et ça reste ma passion quand tu
es commerçant tu aimes tes clients et tu
aimes d'abord leur offrir des bons
produits et donc je suis tout le temps à
la recherche du bon produit il m'arrive
régulièrement de repérer quelque chose
je fais une photo je l'envoie à l'équipe
il dit mais il nous faut ça chez lui
aussi et donc je circule un peu la
comparaison
vous regardez et Dieu et Dieu sait qu'à
à Paris les concepts commerciaux sont en
sont vivants sont en mouvement permanent
donc c'est très intéressant de
d'observer ça de circuler mais après dès
que je peux dans ma rue que je ne
citerai pas il y a un magasin
U Express
il se trouve qu'il y en a un dans ma rue
et vous passez votre vie dans les
supermarchés et quand vous allez faire
vos courses ça vous rappelle le boulot
c'est un peu triste non mais non parce
que c'est un métier passion c'est un
métier passion pourquoi c'est un métier
passion parce que on remet tout en cause
chaque jour en ouvrant les ports du
magasin voilà chaque jour on remet tous
l'équipe on doit être au top au
quotidien ça c'est la première chose et
donc il y a cette espèce de d'obligation
de se remettre en cause ensuite parce
que on est au coeur de la vie des gens
et c'est ça qui me passionne et c'est
peut-être un peu pour ça que finalement
vous m'avez un peu aussi invité
aujourd'hui on est on est au contact
quotidien des Français ils nous parlent
on les observe ils parlent à nos
collaborateurs moi je parle à mes
collaborateurs les hôtesses de caisse
tous les vendredis soirs je vais voir
mes hôtesses de caisse dans mon magasin
et elle m'apprennent chaque semaine
quelque chose sur la vie des Français et
donc ça nous permet de sentir les choses
de voir venir les choses et puis
d'adapter notre commerce à tout ça et ça
on ne sent ne se lasse pas parce que ce
n'est jamais pareil là pendant le covid
les Français ont découvert le commerce
de proximité voire même directement
acheter chez le producteur aller voir
l'agriculteur aller voir le celui qui
cultive la terre qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez leur dire pour les séduire pour
leur dire venez plutôt dans nos grandes
surfaces plutôt que dans votre petit
commerce de proximité et est-ce que vous
allez trouver les mêmes produits il y a
eu un boom pendant le covid vous avez
raison avec un intérêt mais parce qu'on
n'avait plus de temps parce que on était
à la maison en télétravail on allait
faire les courses etc et puis il y avait
ce mot d'ordre qu'on a relayé nous-mêmes
de soutien la production française qui
avait besoin d'écouler ses produits mais
très vite quand la vie a repris tout ça
a reflux et les gens disent quoi dans ma
vie quotidienne j'ai des enfants je
travaille j'ai pas le temps de faire des
courses à plein de points différents
donc nous ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
par exemple quand vous allez chercher
votre panier de fruits et de légumes
chez le maraîchi on essaye d'avoir des
fruits et des légumes aussi bon la
salade en saison la salade que vous
achetez dans mon magasin à 8h30 quand on
ouvre dans la semaine et cueilli à 4h
dans le champ à deux kilomètres du
magasin je travaille avec un maraîcher
depuis longtemps qui d'ailleurs pendant
la crise a essayé de faire des paniers
en avant du quelques-uns mais à arrêter
parce que le modèle économique n'était
pour lui pas au rendez-vous il nous
préférez à nous-même alors vous savez
Dominique Schoelcher qu'en France le
repas occupe une assez large place et
que c'est souvent autour d'un bon plat
que c'est nous les meilleures histoires
c'est la brève de comptoir
on vous a demandé Dominique Schoelcher
de réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas et pourquoi pas en politique
est-ce que vous en avez une à nous
raconter absolument j'en ai une toute
récente
qui qui est la suivante voilà on
rencontre tout au long de l'année pour
parler de notre métier ou répondre à
leurs invitations un certain nombre de
politiques à tout niveau dans les
ministères ici à l'Assemblée nationale
ou au Sénat et récemment j'étais invité
par une ministre à dîner dans un
ministère c'était la première fois on
les rencontre mais souvent on ne mange
pas ensemble et là c'est la ministre
délégué à la formation professionnelle
Carole Grandjean qui a invité trois
chefs d'entreprise pour un dîner un soir
au ministère du travail puisque ces
bureaux sont au ministère du Travail et
dans une démarche très ouverte très du
curiosité sur voilà
vous en êtes où de la formation chez
vous que devons-nous améliorer nous
pensons à ça est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne idée de ça et j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant une première
fois que vous étiez consulté sur
sur ce thème là oui on est consulté très
régulièrement les cabinets nous
consultent régulièrement mais autour
d'une bonne assiette il faut dire que la
cuisine du ministère du travail était
très bonne vous souvenez ce que vous
avez mangé c'était la première fois il
me semble qu'il y avait du poisson il y
avait un très bon dessert un très bon
dessert et puis une entrée très comment
dire faite de légumes de mémoire on a
très très bien mangé on a eu un très bon
échange et si vous voulez voilà cette
proximité d'un ministre d'une ministre
en l'occurrence pour faire mieux
finalement dans sa mission j'ai trouvé
ça formidable et je pense que c'est une
très belle illustration de ce qu'on peut
faire je pense que les Français ont
besoin de ça de se dire que leur
ministre sont proches quoi alors on va
continuer à parler de proximité mais de
supermarchés aussi avec le végétal qui
connaît un succès grandissant le bœuf
est souvent remplacé par un substitut
végétal alors est-ce vraiment la même
chose c'est le dessous des plats
ça la couleur du steak l'odeur du steak
le goût du steak diront certains mais ce
n'est pas du sexe c'est un substitut
végétal qui se glisse dans nos assiettes
certains restaurateurs plébiscitent
cette fausse viande et les clients sont
à commodes est-ce l'avenir et les
membres de réponse avec Diane karcher
Mourgues et André Lafont
à la carte de ce restaurant des burgers
ou encore des nuggets
mais en cuisine aucune trace de viande
que du végétal même pour le steak ça a
la même texture on peut le smasher de la
même manière qu'un steak classique comme
vous pouvez voir à l'image la base de ce
steak végétal de la protéine de pois
mais c'est pour ça ressemblance avec la
viande que la propriétaire de ce
restaurant vegan a choisi de mettre ce
produit à la carte visuellement c'est
vraiment bluffant en termes de texture
vous voyez que du feu vous n'êtes pas
sur bien sûr qu'il est d'entrecôte on
parle d'un steak haché à la base et au
niveau du goût pareil en fait si on vous
dit pas vous faites pas attention
vérifions auprès des passants
effectivement en dégustant ces nuggets à
l'aveugle la plupart n'y voit que du feu
non c'est pas du poulet c'est que du
c'est du soja on aurait dû le poulet
une belle satisfaction pour Laurent
gbels porte-parole du fabricant de ses
substituts végétaux au succès
exponentiel d'ici 20 ans il croit que la
majorité de la viande consommée sera
végétal une fois qu'on rate le problème
de prix on est pour l'instant plus cher
deux goût on est en 99% aussi bon on
peut y rester 1% à changer à ce moment
là je crois que les gens iront bah si je
peux manger un truc qui est tout aussi
bon mais qui est meilleur pour la
planète pour les animaux pour ma santé
bah pourquoi pas meilleur pour la santé
c'est l'un des arguments phares des
fabricants mais vraiment le cas nous
avons posé la question à cette
diététicienne pour elle la réponse se
trouve dans les emballages de ces
produits quand on voit ces produits là
donc déjà première ingrédient l'eau donc
déjà bon moi ça me met un petit peu mal
à l'aise dans celui-ci on a
en valeur en matière grasse on a 12%
dans celui-là à 14 donc c'est de là moi
j'estime qui sont gras donc bien moins
intéressant qu'une viande beaucoup de
ces substituts ne sont donc pas à la
hauteur en termes nutritionnelle donc en
manger oui mais pas en remplacement de
la viande dans la viande on trouve tous
les assises aminés essentiels dans le
corps a besoin
on ne les trouve pas dans ces produits
là
c'est pour ça que il y a certaines
personnes je pense notamment à des
personnes âgées ou des personnes malades
moi je leur conseille de consommer
plutôt de la viande parmi les produits
les plus intéressants pour présenter ce
à base de soja une protéine végétale
similaire aux protéines animales mais
comme pour la viande des précautions
s'impose pas plus d'un produit à base de
soja par jour selon les autorités
scientifiques
Dominique seter est-ce que vous aussi
dans vos supermarchés vous constatez un
intérêt grandissant pour ces substituer
végétaux cette fausse viande comme on
pourrait l'appeler complètement c'est un
marché qui progresse à deux chiffres
alors qu'il y a encore un tout petit
marché un marché encore de curiosité
mais qui progresse très fort en fait
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans les
années 2010 la viande a reculé la vente
de viande à reculer
progressivement les gens achètent moins
souvent de la viande pour différentes
raisons parce que les jeunes en mangent
moins il y a plus cette obligation comme
dans le temps chaque jour de la viande
en fait il y a des feux planètes sur les
jeunes et il y a l'effet planètes bien
sûr après il y a une pause pendant la
période covid parce que pendant la
période covid tout le monde s'est
retrouvé à la maison et s'est remis à
cuisiner et là les ventes de viande ont
nouveau très fortement progressé et là
on revoit ça ça rebaisse et l'année 2022
pour moi restera comme un espèce de choc
où tout le monde a touché du doigt en
fait le dérèglement climatique les
canicules à répétition avec des morts
les feux dans le Sud-Ouest
des tempêtes à l'autre bout du monde cet
hiver des froid à moins 50 degrés aux
États-Unis et donc
les gens nous disent on a envie que
notre consommation impact moins cette
planète et donc le discours de dire
c'est la viande qui est la plus
impactante en termes de carbone comment
ça porter ses fruits et donc il y a des
gens qui en achètent moins et donc tous
ces produits comment dire progressent
pour autant vous avez entendu il y a du
il y a du gras il y a beaucoup d'eau
c'est pas certain qu'on retrouve les
mêmes non c'est pas certain mais ça
progresse entre ce que vous pouviez
goûter il y a 5 ans en arrière dans ces
dans cette gamme de produits là et ce
que vous goûtez aujourd'hui ils se sont
ils ont fait des progrès spectaculaires
vous en achetez vous vous avez goûté ça
m'est arrivé j'ai une fille qui est
totalement végétarienne
voilà du jour au lendemain elle me dit
papa voilà pour les raisons de
préservation de la planète pour aussi le
bien-être animal elle ne mange plus ni
viande ni poisson juste encore des œufs
et donc pour elle donc c'est intéressé à
ces marchés là et incontestablement sa
progresse et je pense que voilà plus il
y aura les ventes plus les industriels
vont progresser dans la qualité à la
fois de recettes et organoleptiques et à
tous niveaux et on le voit déjà mais le
secret c'est ce que c'est le goût de
viande ou est-ce qu'au contraire elle
n'est pas le goût de viande parce qu'il
y a deux écoles un petit peu est-ce que
ça doit reproduire le goût de viande à
votre avis vous voulez vous avant de les
mettre en rayon vous les tester
vous-même vous les goûtez forcément vous
donner une imprimante nos équipes nos
équipes d'acheteurs testent ces produits
et qu'est-ce qui ressort en termes de
goût
je pense qu'il y aura les je pense qu'il
y aura les deux tendances il y aura il y
aura les gens qui disent moi moi je veux
que ça ressemble à de la viande pour
faire un plat un peu comme avant etc
c'est une tendance et l'autre tendance
c'est non je mange sans viande du tout
c'est différent avec des goûts
différents et je fais une cuisine
différente quelle est la tendance des
deux qui émergera le plus peut pas vous
le dire aujourd'hui on est au début
outre ces substituts végétaux quelles
sont pour vous les grandes tendances du
moment que vous pouvez constater en
fonction des achats de vos consommateurs
alors à court terme à court terme le
sujet c'est des arbitrages par rapport à
l'inflation il y a l'inflation elle est
de 12,6% dans l'alimentaire en France à
descendre sur un an c'est beaucoup c'est
du jamais vu chez nous depuis 40 ans 40
ans et donc depuis l'été dernier les
gens arbitres ils arbitres comment ils
achètent moins de produits frais
traditionnels boucherie charcuterie
poissonnerie fromagerie à la coupe parce
que c'est ce qu'il y a de plus cher dans
le panier on achète moins ça c'était la
première phase il y avait peut-être même
une phase avant mais qui n'est pas
alimentaire ils achètent moins de
bazarités pour se concentrer sur
l'alimentaire la nouvelle phase
actuellement c'est j'achète moins de
grandes marques au profit de la marque
distributeur chez nous le produit U ou
le produit premier prix qui coûte moins
cher tout ça coûte moins cher et
maintenant il y a encore une nouvelle
phase qui est avant j'ai 150 euros pour
mon panier pour 15 jours
avant j’achetais n'importe quoi 50
produits pas maintenant comme ça
augmentait j'en achète plus que 47 un
petit peu de l'inflation mais je
voudrais vous entendre plutôt sur le bio
sur le vrac sur les nitrites dont on a
beaucoup parlé ici à l'Assemblée est-ce
que les Français arbitres comme ça en
fonction de la santé de l'effet sur la
santé arbitrer en fonction de la santé
ça se fait je dirais depuis 10 ans
derrière la notion de bien manger il y a
la notion de manger sain manger sain
pour faire du bien à ma santé ça c'est
dans l'air du temps depuis 10 ans
on l'entend et le bio n'est pas qu'une
réponse et je vais vous répondre de
manière précise là-dessus pourquoi
pourquoi c'est une question de pouvoir
d'achat actuellement c'est plus cher
c'est 20% plus cher que les autres vous
vous le vendez moins et donc on le vend
moins je confirme les moins 7 % en gros
du coup on en achète un peu moins et
d'ailleurs ça pose un problème avec les
filières qu'on a construit le sur le
lait sur le port bio comme on en envoie
moins ces éleveurs qui ont mis en en
comment dire des Transformers se sont
transformés voilà il y a moins
d'écoulement on cherche des solutions
actuellement pour quand même défendre
leurs revenus mais pour moi c'est
transitoire et ça va ça va revenir après
oui dans le manger sain le sang nitrite
a complètement émergé dans pour dans les
tranches de jambes c'est un peu plus
cher
si vous observez
la part de linéaire augmente
régulièrement et il y a des gens qui
sont prêts des clients qui sont prêts à
mettre un peu plus pour préserver leur
santé ça c'est un contestable tout le
monde en a pas les moyens mais une part
grandissante et surtout derrière tout ça
ce qu'il faut qu'on explique aux
Français et je prends ma part de
responsabilité de distributeur pendant
trop longtemps on a plus fait le lien
entre le producteur le paysan et ce
qu'on a dans l'assiette et donc on a
tiré le prix vers le bas on n'est pas
chez u comment dire le le premier acteur
de dans cet esprit là puisque nous on a
plutôt toujours défendu le revenu du
monde agricole mais n'empêche c'est la
tendance il faut qu'on réexplique que
non il y a un paysan derrière ce qu'on
mange et que son travail doit être payé
au juste prix et c'est un discours
comporte depuis longtemps chez eux je
voudrais voir le point de vue du
distributeur parce qu'il y a un débat je
reviens un peu à la viande végétale
Brigitte parce que maintenant on a le
droit de dire steak carpaccio alors
qu'on n'a pas eu le droit est-ce que
vous pour mieux les vendre est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut qu'il y ait ce
mot steak végétal ou au contraire
galette végétale aujourd'hui le sa
parole d'avoir la dénomination steak à
nouveau si j'ai l'impression qu'on a le
droit de de l'inscrire à nouveau un
steak c'est une pièce de viande
un steak c'est une pièce de viande et il
faut utiliser le mot galette moi il faut
pas tromper le consommateur je veux dire
c'est comme il y a un autre sujet
actuellement c'est la shrink flash
certains
producteurs réduisent la taille des
emballages le grammage de leur produit
pour et le vendent au même prix et ça
d'une certaine façon c'est tromper un
peu le consommateur on est contre ça on
se bat contre ça
on traque ça il y a des spécialistes
dans des industries qui sont des
spécialistes de ça depuis longtemps le
phénomène est accentué actuellement
alors on va parler à présent des
discounter parce que justement les
Français se tournent vers ces enseignes
à bas prix qui fleurissent en France
mais n'y a-t-il que des avantages on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte il y a pas un mois qui
passe en France sans qu'un nouveau
magasin de hardiscount n'ouvre ses
portes face à l'inflation et ses
magasins qui cassent les prix on le vend
en poupe mais quelle est la recette
gagnante de ces distributeurs bon marché
élément de réponse avec Pierre Michael
Carniel et janutin
2,15 pour une brique de soupe au lieu de
3 euros 52 chez un concurrent ou bien du
riz à 2,39 au lieu de 3 euros 44 dans
une autre enseigne le secret des
magasins arts discount vendre beaucoup
de références étrangères ou encore des
produits des industries non écoulés et
vendus en stock mais pas seulement dans
une enquête l'association
UFC Que Choisir s'est penché sur plus de
700 magasins de hard discount l'attente
des consommateurs elle est effectivement
sur des niveaux de prix beaucoup plus
bas les marques propres sont des
produits qui répondent à ce type de
besoin et les enseignes de hardiscount
sont des enseignes vraiment spécialisées
sur ces ce type d'offre et on a réalisé
des tests de qualité sur un certain
nombre de gammes ces derniers mois on a
on a constaté que les produits de marque
propre n'ont pas à rougi en termes de
qualité par rapport à des marques
nationales une recette qui fait le
bonheur des consommateurs qui font la
chasse au bon prix
je regarde des prix j'avoue je peux
aller dans deux trois magasins je
prendrai là où c'est plus intéressant
pour le même produit c'est pas la peine
d'aller payer plus la marque pour moi
c'est pas très très important en tant
que la qualité est là après que ça
s'appelle un tel ou un tel le nom qui a
sur les tickets je m'en fiche en fait
j'avais pour habitude de manger bio
régulièrement et en fait il savait qu'au
moment de faire ses courses quand on est
autonome on voit en fait qu'on a du mal
à se tourner vers le bio donc on peut
faire de on préfère se tourner plus
facilement vers ce genre de chaîne
alimentaire
Aldi Lidl ou bien Netto des enseignes
qui grignotent des parts de marché de la
grande distribution d'après un bureau
d'études près d'un tiers des ménages
français poussent leurs caddie dans ses
enseignes pour acheter des produits de
grande consommation
alors soyez sincère monsieur schœlcher
si je remplis mon caddie chez Super U et
le même chez un art discounter lequel
sera le moins cher ce qui a une grosse
différence ou en fait ça dépend des
produits que je vais acheter ça dépend
totalement des produits que vous allez
acheter mais il y a une étude qui vient
de sortir en fin d'année je crois que
c'est UFC Que Choisir qui a démontré
démontré je l'ai lu cette enquête tous
les produits de premier prix sont moins
chers dans nos magasins le numéro 1 dans
le comparatif c'était un confrère et le
numéro 2 c'était Hyper U c'était Hyper U
et donc derrière la l'imaginaire qu'on a
le hardiscount et pas cher et ben
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'il y a
des écarts de prix parfois en autre
faveur et je vous le dis et je l'ai lu
dans Le Parisien l'autre jour c'est très
intéressant c'est une enquête sur le
pouvoir d'achat quelqu'un sur un parking
disait je vais moins chez le hardiscount
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
les prix ont beaucoup augmenté et comme
il n'y a pas beaucoup de choix chez leur
discount quand vous achetez un paquet de
gâteaux pour vos enfants il a augmenté
de 50 centimes ce qui est possible
mais que vous n'avez que ce paquet là et
que vous pouvez pas reporter sur un
autre produit vous êtes enfermé dans un
choix et ça les gens en ce moment
n'aiment pas et bah chez u c'est le
libre choix vous avez la grande marque
le produit Distributeur le produit
premier prix est même le produit local
chez nous le produit local et c'est ce
choix qui fait la liberté du monde on va
trouver moins cher mais est-ce que sur
l'ensemble du caddie ce sera pas moins
cher chez un indice scooter mais je vous
le dis pas forcément aujourd'hui on fait
certains collègues font des coparatifs
et ils sont parfois moins chers que le
hardiscount pourquoi parce que ils ont
fait aussi des démarches ils ont aussi
augmenté leur prix ces derniers temps
par contre ce qui est vrai comme il n'y
a dans un magasin U en moyenne il y a 20
000 références chez dans un magasin de
art discount allemand que je vais pas
citer ce sont 1600 références beaucoup
moins c'est beaucoup moins vous avez
moins de choix moins de tentation et
donc c'est aussi pour ça que votre
panier peut être un peu moindre dans le
hardiscount vous comprenez mais si vous
comparez produits à produits il n'est
plus dit aujourd'hui
qu'il soit systématiquement moins cher
alors pourquoi ça marche parce que quand
on voit les reportages à la télévision
on voit que les ménagères calculent font
du benchmark elles sont au centime
presque souvent assez rude à entendre et
elle se précipite quand même dans ses
grands magasins qui n'arrêtent pas
d'ouvrir des portes je crois qu'il y a
encore un je peux pas citer la marque
mais il y a un énorme magasin qui vient
d'ouvrir à Paris oui sur 1500 mètres
carrés Lidl ou et donc ça prospère ça
prospère parce qu'ils font et je le
reconnais une très bonne communication
ça c'est le premier élément parce que le
deuxième élément c'est une espèce de
refuge en disant ben j'y vais parce que
j'ai moins de choix j'aurais moins de
tentations les gens nous le disent comme
ça mais il faut avoir en tête que vous
ne pouvez pas forcément faire la
totalité de votre panier dans un magasin
comme ça vous êtes souvent obligé de
venir chez nous et c'est là qu'on les
convainc en ce moment souvent que nos
prix sont bas Super U et l'enseigne de
supermarchés la moins chère de France
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les
études des panelistes et Hyper U et
deuxième derrière le leader du marché
que tout le monde connaît donc voilà
nous n'avons pas rougir de nos prix je
pense que en ce moment période
d'inflation les gens sont en train de
s'en rendre compte et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous résistons les
observateurs dont vous faites partie
disait il y a un an ouh là là avec toute
cette inflation ça va être un tapis
rouge pour les distributeurs allemands
moi dans les fêtes je constate que ce
n'est pas le cas parce que nous les
classiques on fait bien notre travail
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
vous réduisez vos marges ça veut dire
que parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
négociations commerciales il y a la loi
égaline qui oblige à payer un petit peu
mieux le producteur alors finalement
comment vous vous y retrouver pour vous
écraser les prix ah ben c'est de la
haute voltige actuellement c'est vrai
donc c'est un équilibre qu'on essaie de
de monter différemment je vous prends un
exemple donc il y a beaucoup de
promotion et il y a une action phare
chez u depuis le début de la crise du
covid c'est chaque semaine quatre fruits
et légumes à prix coûtant pour proposer
un fruit ou un légume d'origine
française on ne prend pas de marge
dessus pour rendre
00 sur ces quatre produits des millions
d'euros laissés aux consommateurs chaque
année mais on trouve un équilibre
différent donc là on a nos acheteurs on
se rattrape sur d'autres produits où on
peut prendre un peu plus de marge mais
c'est ça sous les un supermarché c'est
un peu technique parce que ça s'appelle
la péréquation il y a des produits qu'on
vend pas cher du tout voir en promo ou à
0 comme ceux que je viens de décrire et
sur d'autres on prend un peu plus de
marge mais le fin mot de l'histoire il
est on peut le dire ici c'est 2% de
résultats nettes pour un magasin et ça
c'est publié dans la presse chaque année
2% de résultats net ça veut dire quoi
quand vous venez faire 100 euros de
courses dans un supermarché comme les
nôtres il reste au commerçants 2 euros
les gens pensent souvent que c'est 20 à
25 30 euros il reste 2 euros commerçants
c'est sur les volumes que vous vous
rattrapez
des volumes mais la marge en elle-même
finale elle est moindre que dans
l'industrie par exemple
est-ce que vous vous rattra prendre des
produits de première nécessité parce que
c'est ça finalement qui est important et
c'est ça que les gens mettent dans leur
manière en priorité est-ce que si les
quatre fruits et légumes là vous les
mettez à prix coûtant est-ce que
d'autres pour des problèmes à citer vous
les monter très fortement actuellement
40 % des Français sont à quelques euros
près à la fin du mois chiffre de sondage
récents 40%, c'est énorme donc les gens
comparent les prix ils regardent si vous
n'êtes pas dans le match des prix et
donc si vous ne surveillez pas votre
concurrence pour être dans le bon prix
au bon moment et donc vendre trop cher
comme vous dites un produit premier prix
par exemple vous ne le vendez plus parce
que les gens le voient le comparent etc
donc non on est dans le match des prix
et c'est un équilibre global qu'on
cherche et qui est en train de se
réinventer en ce moment à la lumière de
tout ce qu'on vit vous l'avez dit vous
êtes bien placé dans votre votre
enseigne dans les prix cassés or
pourtant quand on interroge les clients
ils ont l'impression que une Super U
Hyper U peut être à cause de votre image
sociétale sociale Papin vous-même
pratique des prix un peu élevés vous
vous êtes obligé de faire une pub pour
nous bien nous dire attention nous aussi
on s'y connaît en prix bas et on sait
casser les prix malgré notre image
sociétale il y a pas un petit un petit
dilemme je vois tout à fait l'article
que vous avez lu récemment c'est le
grand sujet le grand enjeu de Système U
en 2000 à 23 c'est de réduire l'écart
entre l'image prix que les clients ont
en général de U et la réalité de nos
prix qui est tout à fait performante et
donc c'est vrai nous allons sortir
quatre films publicitaires en début
d'année pour réduire cet écart et se
rendre compte et inviter donc les gens à
venir voir nos prix et je suis persuadé
cette année à la lumière de ce
comparatif qui est fait que on va
convaincre beaucoup de Français de
rejoindre l'enseigne U qui n'a pas à
rougir de son positionnement tout en
défendant un certain nombre de valeurs
c'est-à-dire des filières engagées qui
rénumèrent justement
l'agriculteur comme nos yaourts par
exemple à la marque u c'est un contrat
tripartite avec des éleveurs laitiers
etc ils ont un prix min c'est un contrat
sur cinq ans on peut mixer les deux en
fait on peut mixer les deux la loi
égaline vous diriez qu'elle fonctionne
bien aujourd'hui qu'elle permet de mieux
rémunérer le producteur le consommateur
tout en limitant certaines promotions
chez vous on n'est pas au bout du chemin
Système U à soutenu cette loi depuis le
début depuis sa constitution n'a même
participé au débat émission ce que je
constate est l'inse vient de le dire
c'est que le revenu
agricole a progressé de 16% en 2022
après une première progression de 11% en
2021 c'est le résultat de cette loi
alors certains agriculteurs qui nous
regardent vont peut-être dire c'est pas
parfait c'est vrai mais on a fait un
bout du chemin et on a inversé la
tendance c'est formidable sauf que le
consommateur il a eu en moyenne des prix
de plus 12%. donc finalement qui paye
cette hausse des prix au producteurs
la chaîne se répartit la hausse
l'industrielle en prend une petite part
nous on en prend une petite part et le
client prend une petite part au bout
c'est comme ça qu'on raisonne finalement
dans une petite une petite part oui mais
le gros de l'inflation 2000 22 est dû
aux conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
qu'assurant chéri un certain nombre de
matières premières c'est ça le gros de
de l'impact l'année dernière je vous
donne juste un exemple on sait tous le
blé à fortement augmenté donc le prix
des pâtes c'était souvent montré par
vous comme un des produits qui a le plus
augmenté mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que nous n'avons pas nous avons décidé
de ne pas répercuter la totalité de la
hausse et donc nous allons pris sur nos
marges des pâtes pour ne pas rendre ce
produit complètement inaccessible et
donc nous avons pris une petite part
l'industriel avait sans doute pris une
petite part au départ et le client qui
paye plus cher prend aussi une part il
faut équilibrer ça sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne sinon ça ne marche pas je vous
propose qu'on jette un coup d'oeil
justement au prix des produits
alimentaires et c'est le panier LCP
alors grâce à ce panier que nous avons
constitué et bien on peut suivre
l'augmentation des prix au mois près
avec Hélène mondial qui est allé faire
un relevé des prix pour le mois de
janvier alors on constate que dans ce
panier où il y a des pâtes ou l'avait
dit du chocolat des œufs des produits de
première consommation de première
nécessité au mois de janvier les prix se
tassent avec une baisse de 0,4% bon il
faut pas oublier qu'il y a eu quand même
des très fortes augmentations les moins
précédents mais ça a l'air de se
stabiliser et les plus forte hausses
c'est la farine plus 18% le jambon plus
9,2% et le ton + 6,3% en baisse l'huile
d'olive le chocolat le jus d'orange et
les œufs c'est ce que vous avez aussi
vous tout à fait conformation constate
chez nous chez u pourquoi je augmente
par exemple parce que pourquoi les
producteurs de porcs n'arrivent pas à
écouler leur port on dit qu'il y a une
crise du port de la filière française et
le jambon augmente parce que alors de
mémoire le chiffre ça doit être 60% 60
du coût de revient de d'un port c'est ça
la nourriture animale c'est la
nourriture animale qui a fortement
augmenté l'année dernière donc l'autre
partie c'est
l'électricité de l'agriculteur peut-être
qui a augmenté l'année dernière les
engrais ont fortement augmenté suite
suite à comment dire à la guerre en
Ukraine les engrais c'est donc voilà
tous les intrants pour produire un port
ont augmenté et donc le jambon alors là
on sait qu'on est en pleine négociation
commerciale elles doivent se terminer à
la fin du mois de février Michel Édouard
Leclerc a alerté en disant qu'il y
aurait un mars rouge c'est à dire qu'il
y aura un pic d'inflation au mois de
mars est-ce que vous diagnostiquez le la
même chose je confirme le chiffre que
vous venez de citoyen à l'instant une
petite accalmie au mois de décembre pour
moi est provisoire puisque nous sommes
en train de négocier je vois les
fournisseurs venir nous voir avec des
hausses à deux chiffres qui sont le
résultat de quoi plus tellement le sujet
des matières premières un peu encore
mais beaucoup le problème du prix de
l'électricité de gaz produire un produit
alimentaire c'est beaucoup d'électricité
beaucoup de gaz et donc leur facture
augmente ils viennent nous voir avec la
volonté de répercuter cela ces chiffres
sont justifiés c'est ces augmentations
Indochine la plupart des cas oui de
temps en temps on a des surprises et
donc avec nos benchmarks on se rend
compte que
ils ont oublié de prendre en compte si
oui ça et c'est ça le cœur des
négociations commerciales c'est de
discuter la valeur avec laquelle vient
nous voir les industriels et de faire en
sorte que le prix rendu au client au
final soit le plus juste possible par
rapport à tout ce qu'on sait du marché
donc ça veut dire que le consommateur là
il va payer beaucoup plus cher au mois
de mars Au mois d'avril malheureusement
il va payer plus cher à partir de mars
et je pense jusqu'à la fin du premier
semestre sur l'alimentaire on va tout
faire pour continuer à l'accompagner en
promo etc et on prendra une initiative
très forte dans quelques semaines chez U
pour encore contrer un peu les hausses
qui vont arriver à partir du 1er mars
alors il y a proposition de loi qui est
battue en ce moment à l'assemblée qui
est défendue par Monsieur de crozeilles
dont vous avez entendu parler qui vise à
encadrer les promotions pour les
distributeurs vous êtes assez contre
encadrez les promotions des produits de
droguerie parfumerie hygiène on est
plutôt contre parce que les Français ont
besoin de pouvoir d'achat en plus et
donc de promo justement on vient de le
dire mais le plus important dans cette
loi pour moi si elle passe en l'état
c'est une loi inflationniste pour moi
pourquoi parce que son fameux article 3
qui est encore en cours de discussion
peut-être qu'au moment où le l'émission
sera diffusé ça aura évolué mais je le
dis en l'état actuel si distributeur et
industriel ne se mette pas d'accord au
final du final du final le tarif de
l'industriel s'imposerait ça c'est quand
même du jamais vu dans notre métier
cette proposition de loi est le résultat
de vous n'auriez plus de d'influence sur
le prêt au final dans certains cas plus
d'influence du tout et donc ça voudrait
dire des augmentations encore plus
fortes de prix puisqu'on n'aurait pas
fait notre travail de négociation je
regrette je regrette et on est dans
l'incompréhension que cette loi soit à
ce point le comment dire le résultat
d'un seul lob et et les parlementaires
ne sont cachent pas c'est le syndicat
des grands industriels des
multinationales Lillers qui a proposé ce
texte et qui aujourd'hui arrive en
discussion et je regrette je regrette au
stade où on se parle aujourd'hui que les
arguments que nous diffusons soit pour
l'instant peut pris en compte et moi je
vois un risque je vois un risque à terme
avec cette loi si elle passe en l'état
d'inflation très forte à un moment où je
pense que c'est pas le bon moment pour
les agriculteurs pour pour les
consommateurs après pour les
agriculteurs bien sûr faut trouver des
solutions faut continuer à appliquer
égalim sans la détricoter et la FNSEA
d'ailleurs l'a dit nous on est vigilants
à cette loi parce qu'on ne veut pas
comment dire détricoter et galimie et
une autre partie prenante a pris la
parole c'est le syndicat des PME cette
fois qui sont pas les multinationales
qui ont dit derrière ce projet de loi il
y a plus de fortes augmentation et donc
de baisse des volumes et eux appellent à
la suppression du fameux article 3 donc
j'espère à la suppression de cet article
absolument ou alors à sa réforme
profonde distributeurs sont sur votre
ligne à ma connaissance aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous en phase sur ce sujet-là qui
est vraiment poussé le curseur
l'histoire des lois puisqu'on est chez
LCP l'histoire des lois qui touchent
notre métier c'est une histoire de
curseur une fois en faveur un peu du
distributeur une fois en faveur de
l'industriel une fois plus du
consommateur et ces derniers temps avec
également beaucoup de l'agriculteur
cette fois le curseur il fait comme ça
pour l'industriel c'est pas possible et
pour les profanes dont vous dénoncez le
rôle de lobbing c'est le syndicat des
grandes multinationales de les grands
alimentaires vous pouvez citer quelques
marques par exemple ah bah les grandes
marques tout le monde
Nestlé
selon vous derrière cette proposition
c'est pas selon moi c'est tout le monde
le sait est reconnu c'est dit partout
tous les acteurs de la discussion
alors on va passer à présent au dessert
et c'est le péché mignon
on a compris que Monsieur chachère
aimait bien la pâtisserie et il nous a
demandé de lui servir un petit moelleux
au chocolat un moelleux au chocolat ou
un mi-cuit parce que si jamais on pense
que c'est le premier geste que va
guetter monsieur chelcher c'est lorsque
sa cuillère va attaquer le moelleux
est-ce que le cœur sera coulant si les
coulant c'est plus vraiment un moelleux
c'est ce qu'on appelle un mi-cuit c'est
une recette qui a été inventée par
Michel Bras en 1981 et c'est délicieux
donc on va on va faire le test et on
verra si c'est un moelleux ou un mi-cuit
où il y a encore le fondant il y a trois
petits gâteaux au chocolat comme ça qui
sont proches les uns des autres mais
visiblement c'est le moelleux qui est
qui a vos faveurs
on goûte on goûte alors là l'aspect déjà
alors je dirais que c'est plutôt
alors
mais attention parce que c'est Françoise
à préparer mais c'est vrai que là il a
été réchauffé je pense que c'est plutôt
un mi-cuit cette fois oui mais il
devrait encore plus coulant si j'étais
un mi-cuit c'est plutôt moi je dirais
plutôt un moelleux d'accord il y a des
balles
en tout cas ce qui est important pour
moi en répondant à votre invitation
c'était que ce soit un dessert au
chocolat et j'aurais apprécié n'importe
quel dessert au chocolat puisque on en a
parlé tout seul je ne bois pas d'alcool
je ne bois pas de café j'ai un péché
mignon c'est le chocolat voilà
le choc est bien sûr un petit un petit
carreau de chocolat comme ça 70% ou même
jusqu'à plus non mais tous les chocolats
j'apprécie c'est curieux j'apprécie un
très bon chocolat noir comme je peux
apprécier un très bon chocolat au lait
avec modération bien évidemment et
chocolat blanc on dit que c'est pas du
chocolat quand on est amateur c'est vrai
je suis beaucoup moins amateur eux tout
à fait mais vous êtes amateur au point
d'aller parce que maintenant on voit des
chocolateries qui qui prospèrent d'aller
chercher un cru du Venezuela un cacao de
Madagascar un Cryo un petit cru rares il
m'arrive il m'arrive entre deux
rendez-vous à Paris de marcher dans les
rues de Paris ce que j'adore faire de
passer devant une chocolaterie de
m'arrêter et de choisir un bon cru et de
découvrir une production et par exemple
alors il a une connotation un des
meilleurs chocolats pour moi sur Paris
actuellement c'est le chocolat d'Arnaud
Larher qui doit avoir trois pâtisseries
chocolateries dans Paris son nom est
d'ailleurs peut-être d'original
alsacienne je suis pas renseigné de
savoir s'il était vraiment alsacien en
tout cas ces tablettes sont absolument
somptueuses alors vous dans vos magasins
vous en vendez beaucoup vous du coup il
y a une offre qui est plus étendue ou je
suis toujours vigilant au rayon chocolat
et on fait notamment en Alsace encore
des grandes campagnes de chocolat de
Pâques c'est vraiment très spectaculaire
et c'est pas la cloche où c'est pas
l'oeuf en Alsace c'est le lièvre de
Pâques donc les chocolats que nous
vendons le plus ils ont une forme de
lièvre de Pâques en chocolat et bien sûr
encore à Noël donc là oui je suis
vigilant à mes équipes quelles aient les
bonnes quantités de chocolat pour les
fêtes c'est le bon chocolat parce qu'il
y a aussi trop de chocolats
qui sont des confiseries avec beaucoup
de sucre moi personnellement bien sûr je
fais attention je quand j'achète une
tablette je tourne d'abord la tablette
et je regarde les ingrédients si le
sucre est en premier je l'élimine
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de politique à table
sur LCP
[Musique]